what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to a clip from the
whatever podcast
um this podcast has been breaking the
internet recently um I believe they're
located in California
um and they always have a group of women
to give their opinions on a lot of
different dating topics and I'm sure
they're always reasonable as usual so uh
roll the clip King for talking to a guy
and you're really interested in him you
wanted to angle for a relationship you
wanted exclusivity with him one of his
conditions for exclusivity was that you
stop going out and partying do you
accept that or do you say hey you're not
gonna let me guess
this is controlling troll me I'm gonna
do my own thing I'm gonna go party oh
MLD guys shout out to MLD he's in this
um I met MLD like a year ago at um
Donovan Sharp's masculinity conference
and yeah shout out I'm oldie leave it
personally I wouldn't accept that just
because I think a huge part of partying
at least for me is going out with my
friends like I love going out with my
friends my guy friends my girlfriends
it's just always a fun night like no
matter where we go even if we don't find
a party it's just the whole spending
time with them and just bonding I mean
we all we hang out outside of partying
too but so okay I want to give a little
perspective where I do give her point of
view
um oftentimes especially when you're
younger like in college you have a
friend group and the issue with us as
women is we don't see the long term we
see the short term and
um I do remember in college the the
girls that had long-term boyfriends on
our team were a bit like they weren't as
close with us because they spent more
time
um with the boyfriend and you know
especially the ones that like had one
all throughout college or whatever and
um
the thing is girls that feel this way
are so sad that they're missing out on
time with their friends maybe the
attention whatever it is that they don't
see the long term that most of your
college friends aren't really going to
last that long
um how many people do you really deal
with day to day and it's a lot more
important to find a partner that you
have something in common with
um and that you could build a future
with because you know your college
friends they might stay they might not
but the the future is what's is what's
important I think that that would make
me a little bit upset because he's
taking away time from my friends but I
understand my kind of goal going into
partying was oh I'm gonna go to this
party I'm gonna find a guy I understand
that and like the one thing that these
girls don't think about is they don't
think about it from the men's point of
view you know as women we're constantly
being approached even just I mean you
hear us on the show whenever we talk
about this their response is always well
I get approached everywhere that's true
come on let's let's just be real here
you get approached more in a bar or club
party than you are just walking down the
street I mean men are afraid to approach
approach you nowadays
um and you know when there's drinking
and alcohol involved stuff might pop off
so a lot of times like men are making
decisions to protect us but we don't
look at things in good faith like we're
looking at it from our point of view so
we're thinking while he's so controlling
I don't get to do what I want but
instead of thinking you know what he
might be trying to protect me and
protect our relationship for me
personally but a lot of women haven't
had a good model to look up to
down just slightly
slightly well if it's like a condition
like you have to I would say no but at
the same time like I would be down to
probably hang out with like my boyfriend
or the guy I'm talking to instead of
like going out on Friday night but it
can't be like every Friday night I'm
just gonna give up just for a guy like
I'm like no I do not listen to men uh
let's go inside you don't listen to men
no no why am I going to even if he is my
boyfriend am I gonna marry him I'm 21 I
don't think I'm gonna marry him so if I
want to go out with my friends and party
I'm gonna go out with my friends and
party I really don't care if he's
telling me not to go because nine times
out of ten he's probably going to bars
and Party part and is probably
partnering with his friends so I'm
guessing that exception's probably just
for me is he also gonna is is that not
allowed for him either is he also gonna
go party or is he is that just for me
he's not gonna he doesn't party then
maybe
okay but do you see how a lot of times
like women we go into with bad in bad
faith do you see what she her first
reaction was oh well is he gonna party
too like like your first reaction is
combative instead of maybe if I'm
picking a guy he's going to be a good
guy but like so many times as women like
we've picked bad guys in the past and so
we make all the men in our future pay
for those mistakes
if it's the same way if he's not gonna
go party then maybe it depends how much
I like him you just want to be loved
yeah I do want to be loved but I'm not
gonna go make these exceptions for a guy
to be honest that's not I'm 21. he's not
telling me all in all he's not telling
you to accept some like abusive standard
she's like you're dating a guy he's like
yeah I don't go out and drink could you
not go out and drink too you're like
well it'll let men tell me what to do
like well yeah because if he's already
trying to control what I'm doing and who
I'm going out with what I'm doing in my
free time that that might be the start
of something toxic and I don't want to
put myself in that situation let's just
I'm 21 years old I just
sorry no you go out and drink with your
friends I'm sorry but you're not the man
for me and I'm I immediately would lose
that interest because I'm not gonna I'm
sorry but I'm my own person I have free
will and I don't think I love somebody
enough to just be like
drop everything and just listen I am my
own person
but see
we are so used to having women lead
relationships and I genuinely believe
this is because of how the marriage laws
are today you know if two people are in
a contract and one person has more to
lose which which is men in most cases
the the men are always going to be
trying harder to work out to figure
things out than the women always and
that's why genuinely I think that the
laws today change how men and women
interact with each other but circling
back like we've seen so many
relationships where our moms lead our
moms you know wear the like that's why
they say she wears the pants in a
relationship
um that the idea of listening to your
husband is like absolutely foreign to a
lot of women never heard it Natasha were
you going to respond during no wait okay
so well I'll address it really quick why
not we can address it really quick since
it's interesting um so you said that you
wouldn't change any of your behaviors
when you get into a relationship but
isn't part of a relationship you do
change certain and things for example
you no longer sleep with other people
assuming you're in a monogamous
relationship obviously yeah you I think
it's best to grow when you're in a
relationship it's only it if you're
benefiting and you're growing in a
relationship good but if you are unhappy
and if you're not happy like staying
home with that with your man and not
gonna you would rather be partying break
up with him don't be with him because if
you'd rather be partying go do that it
doesn't you're not committed to be
stay-at-home girlfriend with your man
and just listen to your man because is
that man providing for me financially
probably not is does he have a ring did
he so and this is a point
um that a lot of girls don't think about
just because he's not providing
financially for you now it doesn't mean
he won't in the future
um
I I think women typically want to retire
earlier than men do you really want to
be working in your 50s and your 60s you
know
um I think most men would prefer that
their women stay at home so you know he
might not be in the position now to do
that but he very well could work out
something in the future if you're if
you're with a man that loves and
respects you
um so a lot of times again we go into
things in bad faith well what is he
doing for me instead of assuming the
best in someone put a ring on my finger
anger probably not is he gonna put a
ring on my finger probably not I'm 21
years old probably not and I'm not
looking for that I'm not looking for
that that's okay I'm not looking for
marriage at 21 years old and I don't
think I'm gonna find a high value man at
this age because there isn't any high
value men at this I mean it's actually
at 21 years old that's the best time to
be looking for high value man but go
ahead do you want to come in Jungle
who's the guy that made you made you
like this
wait did you just do this
why do you think a man has made me like
this who do you think somebody
definitely hurt you no guy has hurt me
she's just born with all this angst and
hatred
why because I have Valley and like
values that aren't traditional
saying anything listen just because I
want to listen just because doesn't mean
just relax relax okay just because I'm
wearing a suit doesn't mean I'm
traditional it means I'm professional
all I'm trying to say is he asked you
like a very simple question but you came
back with like a fiery emotionally
charged answer that was kind of like a
little bit anti-male and so kind of I'm
trying to figure out like yeah like what
happened and I've only really ever been
in one really serious relationship and I
was the one who went guys should I let
Ellie join the reaction you wanna join
it come here no you're gonna go on the
couch that's a bad move
all right Child come here come here okay
never mind guys never mind never mind I
did it because I thought that it would
be more fun to be single and I've had a
really great time being single and I
honestly can't remember so happy I am
happy I'm not looking for a relationship
yeah I've been on like dating sites but
if you look at the people that I match
with or the people
like my messages there really isn't none
because I haven't found that hot but
then why have the profile to begin with
like you don't have to have the profile
or even sleep with I value men nine
times out of ten they're not on dating
apps that is correct that's like high
value women nine times out of ten are
not on dating apps what makes a high
value woman oh God what's that can
Concepts form to you Concepts foreign to
you modesty modesty being demure modesty
what does modesty yeah modesty and
character modestine appearance modesty
in her demeanor you just don't like it
when a woman is out can you imagine if
all of us American women got exported to
like Eastern Europe or Russia
we wouldn't even know what to do because
we could not compete oh my gosh we could
not okay you're intimidated by that you
just met me like 10 minutes ago okay I'm
starting to say you just called me a
[__] I have not insulted you I said
that you are intimidated that you are
intimidated and nobody's intimidated by
you first of all I don't know oh my gosh
that's the worst when girls think that
like the average dude can beat you up
nobody is intimidated by you I swear to
God I'm so tired
I'm so tired
so tired second of all yeah it seems
like you're intimidated by somebody that
like that speaks the truth that modesty
that is okay that is your concern
modesty so yeah most men are concerned
with modesty to some degree some guys
more some guys less but you know even
guys like destiny that have open
relationships
um I don't think he would be good if if
she was sleeping with a hundred percent
of his friends you know
um every guy has a limit every guy has a
limit you
value woman the first thing that came
out of your mouth was modesty that is at
the top things that came out is that at
the top of the list modesty no then why
did you name it can we can we just lower
the temperature a little bit just she
gets it triggered as [__] I would say I
really don't blame man for getting their
passports to be honest um if this is
what we have to offer women
um
not everything that men say is an attack
just because they have a preference it's
not an attack
um men are not intimidated by you
um especially if you're an average
looking average chick like
they can they can beat you up easily
it's not anything
um but guys let me know what you guys
think in the comments subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time